good Eve everyone in eps10 media
emergency evacuation that's all please
note it this meeting will be for Munich
or should you be required to evacuate
the building would you please leave the
room by the door to the fire escape
staircase just a minor please hold both
have raised in case of stairs I went and
slippery something Winston's if anyone
is unable to use the stairs with a
please allow others to exit the room
before they go go to the fire escape for
escape door where they can be given a
sentence our 70-point will be the public
car parked at the side of the civic
center or ceiling sweet please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
Bahamians please do not return to the
building until given permission do so by
council stuff ok and apologies for
absence
just o'clock just pass me on here
anytime just capsule on you George is
not here because his wife just come here
hospital this afternoon so no right any
substitute numbers non members attending
you had copies of the minutes of the
last meeting held on 70 symbol is
everybody happy sign of those as an
accurate record agree really good
receive declarations and interest we're
on to item 6 already taken to okay for
me you've got the document goes with it
sure oh thank you to i'm just-just
actually the thing you're thinking about
importance there's really two main
elements to it and it occurred to me
that we were dealing with those
separately so perhaps i give a brief
introduction in relation to the the
suggested mean project work streams
first and then we can perhaps come back
and have a bit of a chat about member
responses as a second element of of the
report members who were at the waiting
poor members were circulated with the
with the information will
I think be familiar with the the two
appendices to report on PG 6.4 and 6.5
and this was our attempt to graphically
illustrate the proposed to made elements
allow the initial suggested work for the
Investment Board the first on page six
point four looking at maximum maximizing
Ares's and the three suggested work
streams in relation to that were around
a comprehensive review of the of our
assets the second work stream related to
development options and proposals in
rochford and the third term Don 6.4 as
as major assets project I think more
more more focused on options for
developments in in hockley and really so
the the the other parts of the district
and what the we've set out in those in
those appendices is I think some initial
thoughts around outputs and outcomes
from from those projects now I think
what we would look to see happening in
due course would be the each of those
streams and I'll talk about the pendants
to in a moment each of those streams
would be further broken down into their
own individual work work plans and that
would be something that we would see the
project office that we've set up
focusing on and they've started some
sort some work on that on that task of
already in terms of appendix to this is
looking at options for large-scale
commercial projects and the two
initial projects identified there one
around the idea of developing
crematorium in the district and the
second project stream around options and
opportunities in relation to hockley
wounds and the and the country car so
that that's my way of initial
introduction what I would say is that
whilst there's I guess call it we will
55 projects five project streams
identified there as things stand at the
moment it's clearly going to be the case
that other projects will will come
forward and you know will develop those
into into project plans as as is
appropriate with the with the with the
the decisions of the above the
Investment Board so that's perhaps
enough on on the initial initial
projects and then if I may come back and
talk about project sponsors in a moment
certainly okay any questions once the
book Nucky's I'll come back in a minute
but it so each so so as I've set out in
the report the the notion is that each
of these five streams would have a
member sponsor identified and the the
notion around the the role of the member
sponsor would be I think a champion for
for each each project help helping to
make it happen if that makes sense to be
a critical friend to bring some
expertise to the these the area of each
work stream and to be a public face of
the project so we had in mind
sort of the sort of four key strands
that the that the the member sponsors
would focus on and we're doing some
further work around those those those
for building points in terms of building
up a more detailed briefing sheet for
each for each month member sponsor and
that will be available in in in the
not-too-distant future in the meantime I
think what we would also suggest is that
once member sponsors are identified for
each of those streams will organize a
briefing session to discuss those rules
and relationships and talk a bit more
about the the program program office and
how that's how that's taking shape and
so on so really tempting that's that's
all over to say other than clearly I've
asked the investment board to to
actually nominee to member sponsors to
to each of those five streams and then
we can start taking forward the the work
in more detail okay thank you just to
say I think I've been fairly close to
them on public a study
because I've been talking through you
use the county colleagues and other
colleagues relating to heaven sent out
for you so I'm happy to check their
forward clearly of the process will
bring bring back to this meeting aspects
of how that's going any problems so on
and so forth really anything that really
clarification or and indeed if there's
any expenses or that may have been curve
for the council relating to that project
going forward I think really we should
have handle on those sorts of things and
indeed to whether it's a worth of
projects or not indeed because it may
not be something you want to go forward
with in the end that one if members are
happy with me to do that well I have got
some little pieces that I've spoken to
people on Ginsburg to me and first of
all I'll go start off with the asset
review site again I would quite like to
as it sort of comes down to my portfolio
to initially kick that off because i
feel it needs to be broken down into
component parts for example I've broken
it down into four confirmed parts blend
of buildings that are on long-term
leases for example dirt and at the
moment there's not a lot much we can do
with but we may want to come back little
as a later date land and buildings it so
shall we look after for us for example
woodlands trust we may want to know
those in greater depth as to where
they're going to be continuing that
relationship areas of land that could be
developed sites accept both sets of
example Frank Allen when you talk about
with the one project but there's a
number of others
that we need to identify that could be
some interesting projects next one I got
was laying that in itself can't be built
on but maybe of used to developers for
example if we've got any ransom scripts
dotted around Oh something so there may
be opportunities there the other area is
that and I've been talking to Angela
regards to doing a review to make sure
that we have got all of the our land
holdings in the attic register to go
through that and make sure there's
nothing that hasn't been transferred and
the others may need a bit of land a
scientist code for example when we
discovered it was actually still
registered on the phone radium overcast
so that's that's what I would like to
continue doing once we've broken down
those those particular parts of the
asset register I would like others to
come forward and perhaps take on board
and help work with me as to where we
need to develop on how we need to go
forward with those so that's what I'd
like to put a little team together
behind since on that took one else here
and I did teeth and I didn't have a chat
with regards to one project and keith
was possibly interested in perhaps
working with that themselves works on
the end i'm keith is quite knowledgeable
on their side so perhaps people do
though I think that having to do it can
I suggest chairman concern as Terry's
immediately volunteered one volunteer is
worth temptress managers a leader and I
will be perfectly content to a system in
any way I can they did okay heavy that
that's fine John has expressed an
interest with as far as the crematoriums
concerns it was a worrying thought but
it is something I'm quite interesting i
think it's an amazing commercial
opportunity probably connected if it is
actually feasible I think there's going
to be quite a lot of creative thinking
about how you create a piece of it's
coming for it and then horse has aptly
away Dave like exactly where in the
district it might be best let's put and
I suspect Terry that and my pool that
will be looking to SS County Council to
help us with you know that sort of
understanding of particularly
infrastructure alee issues where it's
best situation and where traffic flows
come into consideration but first it's a
consideration of whether or not there is
a commercial opportunity there one that
we that we can take forward our cells or
maybe a joint venture with a man and a
certain hold on expertise of other
members are no Keith in particulars
heads quite a lot of experience
sanatorium I've learned them here I I
avoided same chairman if I me I mean I
think you make a very good point there
and and you know the energy recall from
the bait for the minutes of the first
meeting that the members sponsors when
identified will decide you know to other
members to bring any may not be members
of necessarily of the of the ID and
behind that there'll be another be an
officer team that you know will be
assembled but you know again officers or
consultants are American you know can
can can be identified as recovery part
how am I glad you raised that because I
saw in the neighborhood we're going to
have to ask unfinished business from a
members good perspective and of course
there will be a project manager if you
like it will be an officer who will as
you say need to have people on the
ground to do to work with regard to the
project as it goes forward I would kind
of like to see that if we have a task of
finish group we brought the whole flock
together and then we have the M here we
have the opposite team and the member
teams together rather than writing it
will create a more cohesive other this
is very sensible because you Mercedes
and millions petites of each other
rather than do it separately and then
find out all one doing one thing or
well I mean that's very sensible that's
a city hope that members of the version
projects will call on the expertise of
all members not just a minute it's
absolutely a frequent user popular words
myself with my family of a quite
interesting being involved in a project
go there on let's take frequent basis
all that next one I was going to come to
is Joe partly because it's her portfolio
with as regards Hollywood's and the
country park which also includes layin
right up so far as Crawford has it might
be a good idea for her to do that others
that were interesting because it's going
to be quite a big one because there's so
many various aspects of it near as well
as expressing interest and so George or
so I think you've already got a bit of a
team they're already up Joe so no but
like aesthetically it's a nice the
Chairman's drinking just to say I think
with the forthcoming developments that
they may well be and this is looking
into the future really on the set up our
chasm Aziz now there may well be some
106 benefits that come to the council
and some of those will hopefully go into
the country park so I think we really
need to consider your balance there
against anything as we might be relieved
in a box I want to do anything under
this area where we get fun
from outside sources that would actually
do that so I think there's a has to be
Earth's orbit you know the eyes on their
testing make sure we're doing the right
thing rather than doing something that
battery it funded elsewhere there's all
sorts of possibilities research and how
to part time and Sean's already got my
wish based on that one Timmy from sure
as well strategies know they're so I've
got an inkling a bit of God raised in
here so but yes it's you have lots of
ideas from the depends to you know all
sorts of things you know one of the
things we used to cover the carnival
which was very very well and what time
we get a lot of dog walks in the county
park was a dog show it's more there you
go so just clean the mess up after this
okay the only other one that if they
believe is the matrices project which
sure Ruby too I don't know if anybody
has got any particular thoughts on that
think there's a lot more to come forward
gender than this all with regards that
before we were really that much that's
that's correction but there are 12
things already beginning to bubble in
the background
I should very much be too specific about
this public meeting bit but there are
wanting to things begin to bubble in the
background so it'd be good to get a
sponsor identified for the sort of
hockley really site side of things right
we possibly do that without knowing what
the implications I want to build another
prison whatever I know you can do so I
think once we got a place if we can
start to look at what we do that people
so you're gonna leave a little bit yes I
think that's something everybody yeah so
very moderate member wants to step up to
the plate please be by leaping off the
cliff isn't it you don't know where
you're in going into it no if the tides
it around please undo that's right okay
anything has some funny ass wants to
trace in are you in the bottom tube
that's fine
it's actually regards to the crematorium
phone what we meant will likely
mentioned the fact of the new burial
ground which we're looking to bring on
string you're talking about allroad
correct I wanted to see the
investigation as to what the acreage was
because then we could work out the flow
I i did a health look at what the
potential flow cash flow was and it was
looking at between three and four
million pounds in that area with the
plot sizes which are recommended by the
National burial Association and I feel
that it should be married up to some
extent i know the crematorium this
probably will be a big item but i think
they kind of married together somewhat
with a view that we need to have cash
flow coming in and i believe that the
setting implodes and bury you mind
obviously with the crematorium you're
going to be looking you know a various
outside of ice buying probably funeral
directors and such like because that's
the sense of the way of going about it
and we'll take the view for sale on how
they view the way that these things
compared there is some of them or
independently through an independent
company if we say that's another view we
all have to take but i think that it'll
be a good idea to ensure that we have
cash flow coming in obviously the
crematorium is going to be a large
product that's going to require quite
considerable finance and and if we've
got an age where we know we
even longterm cash flow coming in from a
resource that we have when we can
demonstrate we have because it's
guaranteed and it's probably the only
thing that's guaranteed I think that's
worth while exploring in Tony you wanna
come on yeah by the way your heart no
seriously would you young Iranians be
happy to work I do agree that it's a
good car so sure or alternatively just
occur to me and maybe I have another
good at the at the other other major
projects thing it does occur to me that
that might be rolled into into that
other work stream and if it helps I
think that I think there are issues
around the work that's taking place at
the moment with secretary Housing
Association I think there are issues
around options for what might or might
not happen in relation to the second
rope car park and hopefully library I
think those issues around what happens
for this estate here and so actually I
think that other work stream does have a
number of a number of bits that you know
I'm never respond sir could usefully
identify it usually be identified to
take on and it may be that you know
actually the issue of the cemetery is it
something that would fall into that into
that category yeah and I might take what
you say on board Sean but at the same
time it is an allied subject and you've
got to fund you know the not just if
there's laying and land acquisition than
you need
fund it if we already have the land ago
but you've actually got to to actually
fund the project so what Ian's actually
suggesting is that there's an income
stream there so an able to do that on
our own rather than necessary Sika Sika
join partner if we are confident enough
of doing it ourselves then of course we
maximize the income in future years and
hopefully perpetuity but I think we're
going to have to let these things will
fly and if we miss that out of the
feasibility study for the crematorium
then we've made a mistake if on the
other hand we see is part of the
feasibility it isn't actually
conditional upon that going forward now
of course it can be moved you know quite
quite happily into another work stream
which is better or its own work string
so flexibility is the issue and it's a
good introduction through each other
like concise interesting when you look
at the south end credit promotora in
relation to the cemetery that's there
but you know it's it's or lends itself
to each other if you are yet so and
white the other thing you have to
consider is you know if you have a
crematorium clearly you might have some
Willoughby small services you're going
to have to have that sort of this you
know as we shall attend to be a big
enough to accommodate and of course
you're going to a donut parking you
never come out that because not the
problem with the south end time I'm
experiment up short unfortunately most
of us have been there from time to time
is that their overflow in the actual
cemetery because it's right obviously so
I think we need to consider that because
if we got to put it somewhere in this
fairly remote you know who road or
that we might consider you know you've
got to consider me as if they can't park
there where they go you know and you
know it's a question trying to work all
that out and no no the expertise but I
do agree with you in a bit of a you know
a funeral pure agents yes I think that's
a modality medicine from you know I
could say that people are going to use
it basically suddenly it says it's
really that good talking the absolutely
yes yeah like a question following on
from that the sound plots in a skirmish
at the moment is that done mainly food
and fuel intuitive doing elemental do we
get to exposures and probably don't I
believe we get direct to produce and the
the hood Marcus need to try and like
trying marketers because of the format I
hate what you're saying about the other
world look a funeral directors may be
foolish not to because they know cos
it's a very interesting business long
traditions but i'm still in the way I've
still in the binder most economists my
head markets are changing those sorts of
things you know the easyjet they're
doing easy superbikes now I'm not
sounding like that of an easy coma
torium but the sales structures the
marketing structures why things have
been done for decades is breaking down
and maybe but the time we get the permit
I'm up and running that would be a new
business model ow I don't know don't
think that solution dome Ontario yeah
yeah
you've got a visitor all the angles out
absolutely it's Derek save gas
information for infection maybe we can
develop a new business model yeah which
I think would be very attractive we're
doing in New York to coming in MZ is
there any data or information in
relation to save of burial plots and the
pra's obviously if you thinking of using
that source of income I know from
harrisch are the things that's a parish
number of parish plots is diminishing
year-on-year so it would be probably
appropriate to get some kind of guidance
to going forward what your work
spectators are we by the same I think
markers will be very much ever to
encourage that information I've
researched it yeah seven pounds basic
price for a nine by three you know never
won the maximum size we need to go to I
know market is talking of 10 5 we lose
too much ten-four is it was recommended
and 10 for normally goes for about 9 915
so you're looking at a range between
seven of our 49 mph and bearing in mind
appending on what the heck tillage is to
work out you square the square feet and
do your simple mathematics it comes out
to somewhere in the region of between
three and a half to four and a half
million depending on what you're selling
over a period of time obviously unless
you presale comes through to
the various funeral directors who might
want to take it back if we wish to do a
certain discount if you want cash up
front so I mean again we have to look at
the value model look up you know our
spice our time and and and how we want
to release areas but that's going to bet
obviously a long term look financially
and how we do it one of the things that
when I was doing the environment Joe
will probably know this is the sort
conditions can be a big factor as well
and because last thing you need is one
crying collapsing soon as you're the
nationally do you like that needs to be
taken against we need to be like that's
why i am marcus had recommended its life
original device yeah and a lot of its
for the heavy machinery going on between
yeah there is an aspect here of course
we if we sell all of our stock then and
it's reserved for people who are waiting
if you like then of course we will end
up in a position where we've gotta
create a new supply and we've got to be
thoughtful about how we marketing and we
might have to actually put you know
release caps on otherwise we'll end up
in a sorry situation or special opposite
oh yeah why nonsense thank you one thing
Linson be coming from popular narrow is
the green burial a very in mind the
makeup of our district that may be
something that we could have a nearest
one i think at the moment his friend
would want no we got one of our digital
yes i think that's funny yeah oh I'm not
sure I just absolutely so if you go for
priceline does not know it's the other
side if you go down and even road that
way you stop coming an Anglophone its
container but that's your like that's
pretty to go down there knock each the
service call you come to time
it's on the right of you and yes they do
sort of no stones or something like
those implants I think I think they put
a chip in there or something so they can
identify it something like that and yes
it's that sort of you know with a user
Kabul you know whatever I don't know but
we're going to help okay okay so then
they do something this project obviously
is the most interesting focus as go
south on what get too bogged down the
victor love it here yes we don't want to
read them in the will you because we
gots in between yes we've actually
extended their symmetry if you have a
thousand in it so we've got close so we
know some of the costs wording but I
know that there was when we actually did
that I don't know we discussed the other
time other members will remember a lot
of it and this goes back to what we said
about the plot size in why is that a
little bit was about the preparation
because you have to make sure than a and
is right it's a bit like a football
pitch away you know you have to make
sure it's got the proper training is
limited because as you quite rightly say
what you don't want is you have got
heavy machinery that's going around but
obviously you know very doing your phone
that sort of thing you don't these
things collapsing and you know activity
that would be very upsetting from those
left behind so you know I think we need
to keep given all this careful
consideration we've done some stuff
already so let's make sure we use the
expertise from there interneting me
considering now so I think we have quite
a lot today to work on them and I don't
know what the plot scope for their they
open no I'm not sure and there's a
parish club there is what is the
butcher's robbery listening for the
world yes okay any other points in we
want to race but why we talked about
Barrios enzyme you know there's that
there is a government limitations
number of corpses you can put in Hector
it's 1976 all right just as a matter of
interest so that's fine but you're going
to consider roads and everything else so
that reduces the f2 area yeah okay
anything else wants to this dress
anything first I think you're not seeing
where the interest is such a move on
carefully warning yoga's cliche so
chairman of 95 defy me that that on page
six point three there are two
recommendations Nestor proper food so
there's too many directors on 643
tipping you do you want to take them
secretary or I each have to choose to
accept them and signed off those remote
incidentally there's any one amendment
chillin and that is of course under
number one we were the left one of the
worship next year and cypress village
any British ever nominated a person for
that project yes one spice in abeyance
one specimen is everybody happy with
that we eat a green thank you very much
thank you I think I've just about covers
everything we need to nip syncing
hopefully just threw you chillin these
meetings are fairly quick at alone
because we're looking into the future
and we're considering you know get fuzzy
things it's gone I can see them being
much more something later and there'll
be a lot of preparation in as you say
subcommittees and other committees that
will come forward to this committee so
you know I think they will get a lot
longer
we may go in Providence we may just have
to have one meeting to deal with one
particular project rather than try do
two or three we did the same engine here
that may be the problem okay oh thank
you very mu Tong a lot sorry challenges
by question are we now going to arrange
to meet separately as I subcommittees
with you explain please yes I